news daily from science mission it is  known that sleep facilitates memory  retention and consolidation but the  mechanism is not known authors in the  journal Cell show that in Drosophila  physical activity increases dopamine  release which in turn enhances  forgetting while sleep or reduced  physical activity decreases dopamine  release thereby blocking forgetting and  increasing memory consolidation next  dietary fat and sodium are both known to  synergistically want to be to ingestive  behavior thereby obesity contrary to  this hypothesis in Mainz dietary sodium  prevents weight gain during high-fat  feeding specifically through suppression  of digestive efficiency without effect  on food intake resting metabolic  processes or physical activity high salt  blocks renin-angiotensin system  resulting in decreased fast absorption  and weight loss for more news visitors  at www.hsn smishing facebook